i'm planning to tell my parents that
jenny i and i already engaged couple now
and i know that they will not gonna feel
good about it but this has happened and
i should tell them at a celebration for
his brother and sister-in-law who are
welcoming a new baby smith thought it
was a good time to tell his parents that
he and jenny are engaged but then again
it's 90 day when do they ever find the
right time maybe go back engage too
we'll get into what jenny said that
let's submit to break the news i'm still
a human being even though i'm this old
plus how serious was it it was serious
you know like she introduced me to her
family oh my god corey corey admitted
that his relationship with jenny was
more serious than he made it seem
serious enough that they were planning
to move in together oh my god it sounds
like a venezuelan soap opera well the
drama is just getting started wait until
you hear what he has to do next i'm
gonna have to tell her
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicio
the latest episode of the other way was
full of
[Music]
and people speaking their truth submit
being one of them with me my family if
they say anything to me it's okay but
not to you first let's get into his
conversation with jenny then moved him
to tell his parents that they are
engaged every time they call you and say
come for this reason come for that
reason you go and sometimes i wish you
would just tell them no i'm not coming
because i feel left out jenny was
complaining that she is never invited to
submit family functions because as we
know submits parents do not approve of
their relationship due to jenny being
about 30 years older than smith the
situation that i'm in is
it's difficult it's very difficult to be
so insulted by them and so hated by them
i'm still a human being even though i'm
this old what was up with that hand
movement right there even though i'm
this old
that was kind of funny well the
interesting part about this is that even
though jenny knows she's hated by them
she still wants to be invited to the
gatherings i don't have any of my family
here at all so being with schmidt and
his family would be great for me it
would be wonderful be a dream come true
actually
i get where she's coming from somewhat
because as she mentioned she doesn't
have her own family around but at the
same time are you really going to feel
like you're around family being around
smith's parents who don't want you there
maybe
i don't know i'm just someone that if i
feel as if i am not wanted or welcomed
somewhere
bye you don't have to tell me twice and
i will not ask to come back
we are here to celebrate my wife's
pregnancy fast forward to what we're
just going to call the baby shower for
now
but
smith's parents were ecstatic that
smith's brother and sister-in-law are
expecting this baby will be their first
grandchild
oh uncle submit well before uncle submit
headed to the celebration he promised
jenny that he would stand up to his
parents so she can join in on the family
gatherings from now on and not feel left
out anymore his method of attack
revealing that they are engaged
it's very uh important for me to talk to
my parents
because they don't know uh jenny and i
are we are
engaged now
so it should be clear in their mind that
i think my relationship with cheney very
seriously
and that's why jenny should be a part of
any family event
otherwise i won't be able to come
i am bit nervous my family will get mad
and they will fight with me
a lot of bad things can happen uh yeah
that's why i was a little confused on
why he felt like the celebration for the
baby was a good time to discuss this
before summit actually joined his family
inside his sister-in-law asked his
mother how she was feeling about not
having submit around now that he lives
with jenny and his mom
broke down in tears i feel very bad for
my mom
she oftenly cries for so much
it's affecting each and every person
okay so now that you have that context
here is submit who comes in and says hey
i know i'm here to celebrate the baby
but i have something else that i need to
say which is that i am not okay with the
fact that jenny is never able to be part
of our family moments jenny if she
wanted to be the part of the celebration
we do not have any issue
she is welcome as a friend of simat any
time
not a family member summit's parents
also responded to submit's comments by
sharing that they can't accept jenny in
everything because society would cut
them off meaning that if they ever had a
problem and needed help from a neighbor
or something the neighbors wouldn't come
and jenny is not worth that risk
maybe go back engaged too
well that move right there just ruined
this one
[Music]
that's the worst when someone you love
is so mad at you that they don't even
say anything look at her she just walked
off his brother didn't hesitate to speak
up though mom is suffering from this all
this
as you also know we are extending our
families so i don't want that negative
atmosphere on
my baby
i'm doing nothing wrong
[Music]
i don't think you're asking too much to
have the love of my life and my family
both
this is very difficult situation i don't
know what to do at this point it's
taking more energy for submits parents
not to accept jenny then it would take
for them to just accept her just accept
her all right before we move on to corey
and evelyn cement did say something to
jenny earlier in the episode that i
wanted to share with you take a listen
if people are saying wrong just forget
it because negativity is something which
you remember forever but positivity is
something is hard to remember that's so
real
okay submit thank you thank you for the
nice reminder count your blessings
eat
no
okay now to corey and evelyn two people
who could definitely use some divine
intervention right now
evelyn confessed to her parents that she
secretly married corey a year ago
no
si
and as expected her mom in particular
was devastated
stating
she can't get a divorce my family takes
a family where no one gets divorced i do
feel trapped now that my family knows i
feel like
even if i want to escape i can't and
that's how i feel right now i'm sorry
[Music]
okay
well just like she was so good at
keeping this marriage a secret
i wouldn't be surprised if she decided
to divorce and just kept that a secret
too i bet everything she says now her
family is going to be like
you sure that's the truth
and also what if corey decides that he
wants to divorce her what is she going
to do never sign the papers i do feel
trapped now well if all this has her
feeling trapped i'm interested in seeing
how she's going to react when corey
reveals to her that his relationship
with jenny was way more serious than he
let on you remember that girl i told you
about
jenny during a conversation with raul
who was friends with both evelyn and
corey corey opened up about how his
relationship with jenny wasn't just a
little fling
he confessed that she introduced him to
her family and that they were actually
going to get a place together but evelyn
doesn't know any of that she just thinks
it's like a one-night thing and
god you know kind of thing oh my god it
sounds like a venezuelan soap opera i'm
so surprised because corey's always been
a goody goody guy
and i had him on this pedestal he's like
a saint
but now he's telling me he got married a
year and a half ago and had a glove of
hair with some chick
it's not even a one-night stand it's a
no relationship wow
corey and evelyn both have a lot of
trust they need to build back with
people
they've been fooling everyone
personally i feel bad for jenny this
woman is probably somewhere in peru
feeling ghosted i never actually fully
ended things with jenny i did cut
communication i was not talking to her
for many months then i just left it at
that i didn't reach out to her anymore
once i realized that me and evelyn did
have an opportunity to fix our
relationship
poor jenny
that's not a good feeling come to think
about it she actually dodged a bullet
for one
who wants to be wrapped up in all this
mess i do feel trapped now and two if
corey would lie to evelyn i lied to
evelyn who he loves so much
he will lie to jenny as well dude i'm so
torn right now and i don't know what to
do man thank goodness for raul though he
gave corey some really good advice that
i hope he takes i think you should man
up
go and face jenny
tell jenny you're in love with evelyn i
want to do that so badly but i feel bad
you know like
but it's not about you at this point
corey
how do you think she feels
okay let me relax obviously that hit a
nerve but you should do the right thing
after you tell jenny
to go and face evelyn
yeah if you don't tell evelyn the full
truth about jenny
i'm gonna have to tell her
cory was taken aback by that yep now he
is forced to fess up this gonna be the
hardest thing i think i ever had to do
we just have to wait and see how evelyn
is going to react
meanwhile speaking of reactions next
week it looks like sumit is going to
talk with jenny about how his parents
reacted to his requests for her to be
more involved in family gatherings
mom's not happy so nobody's allowed to
be happy i guess screw your happiness
right
at this point i think that his mother
would do almost anything she can to get
him away from me she's the boss oh she
is the boss all right 90 day fans fam i
won't have a recap for you next week but
i will be back the following week with
all you need to know make sure you stick
with et because we are covering it all i
will see you next time
[Music]
you